es momento de hablar de economía a quién
france24 hoy que es jueves 20 de agosto
y para ello recibimos a la especialista
económica danielle hablando ramírez
daniela pues sigue conociéndose el
impacto económico del cob y 19 en esta
región si al anhelo el turno de esta vez
es para perú que acaba de entrar en
recesión técnica ya que presentó una
contracción de su economía por segundo
trimestre consecutivo en el primer
trimestre del producto interno bruto
había decrecido un 3,5 por ciento frente
al año anterior y en el segundo y al
desplome era el 30,2 por ciento frente
al trimestre anterior la caída es
superior al 27 por ciento este país con
sus casi 30.000 muertos por coronavirus
es el que más golpeada ha visto su
economía en américa latina' alan le
cuento al menos si lo comparamos con
otros que ya han mostrado resultados
para el segundo trimestre como por
ejemplo méxico colombia y chile este no
es un buen indicio si se tiene en cuenta
que antes de la pandemia perú era uno de
los países con cifras más robustas de
crecimiento económico
y al norte del continente de daniela
volvieron a subir las solicitudes de
subsidio para quienes pierden su empleo
en eeuu si con dos semanas seguidas de
descensos en estas solicitudes ya los
analistas estaban confiados en que
vendría una etapa de recuperación en el
mercado laboral pero esto no duró mucho
alan como decimos nosotros fue flor de
un día unas peticiones de subsidios
semanales volvieron a subir de un millón
después de que la semana pasada bajarán
de ese umbral hay que decir que estas
solicitudes no están en un nivel tan
crítico como el que llegaron a ubicarse
a finales de marzo en casi siete
millones pero si son muy altas para el
mercado que venía acostumbrado a
doscientas mil peticiones por semana
pero el empleo es sólo uno de los tantos
indicadores el mercado no está muy
optimista después de que la reserva
federal dijeran las actas de su más
reciente junta directiva que se
necesitan más estímulos si se quiere que
la economía comience a marchar a paso
firme
nos vamos a brasil donde hay tensiones
entre los poderes ejecutivo y el
legislativo en esta ocasión tiene que
ver con los salarios de los funcionarios
públicos en 2021 el presidente ayer
bolsonaro ve todo este ajuste salarial
él argumenta que la crisis por la
pandemia deja al estado muy escaso de
recursos y que el agudo déficit fiscal
impide que suban los sueldos el próximo
año pero el senado anuló ese veto y
ahora será la cámara de diputados la que
decida al presidente de esta corporación
rodrigo maia le gusta más la idea de
mantener los salarios como están pero
admite que los parlamentarios están muy
divididos al respecto
mientras que noticias empresariales la
alemana bayer vuelve a solucionar sus
demandas esto lo hace con dinero si en
esta ocasión la multinacional de
medicamentos y pesticidas aceptó pagar
1.600 millones de dólares para resolver
un lío de vieja data se trata de las
casi 39.000 demandas que han recibido
está en eeuu por el dispositivo
anticonceptivo llamado y short que ya
fue descontinuado en este país desde
2018 este es un dispositivo alan para
que veamos se implanta nuestro pase de
falopio para bloquear de manera
permanente el paso de los óvulos hacia
el útero de las mujeres pero hay quienes
lo han usado que dicen que han tenido
lesiones severas por el uso del mismo
alegan además que las partes metálicas
del dispositivo corren peligro de
desprenderse y migrar a otras partes del
cuerpo este no es el primer caso de este
estilo en junio pasado- bayern hizo lo
mismo prefirió pagar 10 mil 900 millones
de dólares a los demandantes que dijeron
que es un fertilizante brown down
causaba cáncer
y al igual que lo hizo en esta ocasión
esta vez también advirtió que el acuerdo
incluye que los demandantes desistan de
sus procesos y que no admite ninguna
responsabilidad
bien daniela bonos con los indicadores
económicos wall street cerró en terreno
positivo esto a pesar del pesimismo de
la reserva federal y de los malos datos
de empleo en europa los principales
índices presentaron descensos
significativos un común denominador que
se ve en las bolsas de londres parís
madrid y alemania y en américa latina'
descensos en mexico y avances en
argentina y en brasil todos siguiendo
los pasos de la reserva federal
finalizamos daniela con las cifras del
día bueno son los de 100 millones de
personas que podrían caer en la pobreza
extrema por el coronavirus así lo
advirtió el banco mundial esta entidad
agregó que es urgente reducir les la
deuda a los países pobres a las 100
millones de personas daniela pues muchas
gracias por este completo recorrido
económico y por supuesto muchas gracias
a ustedes por su compañía ya lo sabe
para más noticias y al momento no sólo
aquí en nuestras actualizaciones
televisivas sino también en nuestro
sitio web france24 puntocom cuídense
escuece mucho del cob y 10m
e